[Music]
now let's start with a big question
that's important and kind of a
prerequisite for talking about what
dbt is which is talking about who and
what
this workflow this modern
approach to analytics into the modern
data stack
actually is so normally in the course
this is the part where
um i ask the folks who are here to go
around and introduce themselves
i'm just going to introduce myself and
say
again my name is jeremy i'm an associate
product manager at fishtown analytics
formerly um analytics engineer course
instructor
a bunch of other things lots of um hats
on the hat shelf
um so i and a lot of us at the company
have been practitioners
of modern analytics for many years and
dbt grew quite naturally out of that
it was not uh like the
egg that then hatched the chicken it was
very much us raising chickens and then
realizing
um we wanted to apply the principles of
software engineering to
egg farming maybe not anyway i'm calling
from philadelphia pennsylvania
in my bedroom i'm sure
you all are calling from some version of
that yourselves as it's been for several
months
the traditional data team as we see it
and as we
experienced it in a lot of past jobs
experiences consulting engagements
has been one of data engineers and data
analysts
with a explicitly
separate at times even antagonistic
relationship
where data engineers are responsible for
writing
all etl all infrastructure management
and needing to transform data you know
by definition of the etl stack
transform data in advance of loading it
into some
final exposure layer some relational
database like postgres
that analysts can then access it the
role of data analysts being
to write sql to take stakeholder
requests and translate it from
english into sql or from french or
spanish or
whatever other language into sql um
using that sql to then power dashboards
and reports
or any downstream insights work that
they need but
if there are problems with that data if
there are
new columns that need to be added new
business logic that needs to be defined
it requires filing a ticket in very much
the same vein as it would
if the pipes broke or if data isn't
fresh
or any of the other things any of the
infrastructure needs to be upgraded or
scaled up
these are all falling into the same
category of
issues that just need to be thrown over
the wall thrown over the garden fence
from the data analyst team to the data
engineering team
and these two groups of people don't
necessarily report to
the same um person the same team the
same function they might be
down the hall from each other but they
might just as equally be in different
states or countries around the world
and of course the role of the
stakeholder is just to like patiently
wait
wow their english language or other
human language
the requests are being translated into
sql by
analysts who then need to throw them
over the wall to the engineers
so this is not rapid iterative
analytics and it's it can't be on on a
structural level
and there were like real technical and
technological reasons for this
five ten years ago um reasons that an
etl stack is
is necessary but with the advent of the
modern data warehouse
with google bigquery amazon redshift now
snowflake
as well it's just not as necessary from
a technical standpoint to transform all
data before
loading it into the warehouse we sit on
top of the shoulders of giants in
particular
on top of an all-powerful supercomputer
that can handle
storing multiple copies of the same data
over and over again with meaningful
transformation applied on each layer
so for anyone who's particularly
observant you'll see that i've
badly cropped out something in the
middle here this is using my
student licensed adobe illustrator that
i still managed to keep around for a
little
bit data is loaded in by some
external third-party tool good maybe
it's stitch maybe it's five tran
maybe it's something else maybe it's
custom ingest if absolutely necessary
that's where the data engineering team
still serves a vital
function it arrives as what we call
raw data source conformed data in the
warehouse
so it is not structured in such a way
that may make sense to the business it
is structured in a way that makes sense
to stripes api engineers or
zendesk api engineers or stitch and five
tran
writing the ingest for those
if we just directly plug that into
downstream use cases to bi to reporting
to whatever our ml engineers get to work
on every day
there are going to be some problems and
those problems look like
having two or three or five stakeholders
with different values for a kpi because
they've defined it just marginally
differently
or even if conceptually they've defined
it the same maybe they've just forgotten
a little bit of that magic reusable
logic that needs to go everywhere
uh we need to ignore cancelled orders of
course but also somehow false orders who
knew the orders could even be
true um and they can't be deleted right
but this is
uh null uh otherwise time stamp okay
good um oh actually you know one of our
qa people
has user id 12 and they just go in and
try to break a bunch of things all the
time as often as possible maybe it's
even the ceo on the weekends
so we need to ignore their orders as
well because that's noise
if any one of these is something we
forget to write in every single
dashboard or report or ad hoc query that
we pull for our
the person who sits uh down the down the
hall from us
um we're gonna end up with a wrong
number in the sense that we'll end up
with a different one from everybody
else's
that's putting aside the just good
old-fashioned sequel things we can do
to get a wrong number like accidentally
fanning something out because we thought
it was one to one when it turns out it
was one to many
or because the data is missing and it
actually it's monday morning it hasn't
ingested since thursday afternoon
or kind of the most dangerous and subtle
answer of all which is
all the dashboards work all the reports
run
all the queries seem right but we have
no idea how the data actually gets there
and how it gets
from the warehouse into
the email inbox of our ceo every monday
morning
so i see this one as the scariest yet
which is everything works
we don't know why
um feel free to chat in if any of these
experiences resonate with you if
that's not a single one of them does i
would say you live
a charmed life and i end video for it
so you can see this is the same image
from before
without my uh bad crop job
there are a couple of key pieces that
need to sit
in the middle that need to sit in
between
raw data source conformed data and
something that's actually
transformed to be business conformed to
be ready to be
have the same meaningful definitions
applied in modular and reusable ways
and there are a lot of steps that go
beyond just
transformation that go beyond just um
writing the sql select statements
to take orders and return the orders
that we actually want
we should be testing those
transformations as well as testing our
source data that feeds into those
transformations we should be deploying
those transformations
in an automated and scheduled basis to
be documenting those transformations
so that if as does naturally happen
um the really talented analyst
who built a lot of our infrastructure
from the ground up built a lot of our
transformation logic
ends up leaving to go pursue a life of
the arts
um we're not totally at a loss because
the logic has been documented in in uh
human readable language
maybe we need to add some pieces on the
other end maybe we need to snapshot
slowly changing dimensions so that we're
not losing important contextual
information
and to be doing the whole thing in
version control with alerting and
logging along the way
these being in some sense the principles
of software engineering
the recognition being that sql is code
there are things that people do in the
world to build maintain
and qual quality assure code we should
be doing those things too
now i should say it is
100 possible to do every single one of
these things
and never have heard of dbt or written a
single line of dbt code to have never
typed dbt run
into a terminal
our vision for dbt is that it is a
piece of open source software that
encapsulates
this workflow underpins it and is
reinformed by it
so as we get better at thinking about
how to snapshot
slowly changing dimensions within the
warehouse
we feed that better back into dbt and
indeed
members of the community a couple of
whom are on this call right now
have been so kind as to contribute it
back um because
we sit on each other's shoulders as well
as the shoulders of
a super computer um so the ability to
capture hard deletes in snapshots
has long been a conversation in the
community fed back
into poll requests and into code um a
lot of this is
articulated in the viewpoint which you
can read in our docs
here um but also
probably easily googleable
so with all of this comes a notion
of the analytics engineer and this is a
little bit of a
neologism but it's also a little bit of
a recognition
of there is work
that the canonical data analyst may not
be ready for or more often may not be
interested in
at the same time there's a set of
incentives
and responsiveness that traditional data
engineering teams
just have not been aligned with or are
not
reactive to in the way that they should
be
so someone who sits in between the work
of the people who
partner closely with members of the
business
and people who sit
a little further back in the office
maybe doing important work around
infrastructure
provisioning and building custom
ingestion let's talk a little bit about
the fundamentals of dbt and let's do it
using an example that you all can
do on your own
computers with your own bigquery
accounts if you'd like
your own dbt cloud developer accounts
so this is familiar for anyone who's
been around the community for a bit we
talk a lot about jaffles
jaffles are a kind of sandwich though
they're also much more than that
i'm an analyst working at the jaffle
shop we have customers we have orders
this exists in a snowflake warehouse
that i have access to but
critically it is also available as a set
of public s3 files
and a bigquery public data set
so if everyone wants to on their own
time
or right now on your own computers
go to docs.getdbt.com
getting started tutorial
this is going to walk through a little
bit of how to set up
your own bigquery account how to set up
your own dbt cloud account but you can
certainly also install dbt on the
command line and use it there
you can install it using homebrew if
you're on a mac or pip
or install from source so i probably
would recommend pip
it's a python program and
we've got a query that we can
play around with i'm going to play
around with it in
cloud so this is a query
that takes customers
and orders joins them together
finds each customer's first order date
most recent order date number of orders
and it's about 56 lines long which is
you know
not too bad as things go but
still there's a lot going on here
probably more
than needs to be all at once
this is what i get after when i when i
run this query
number of orders most recent order date
first order date
and what i want to do is take this magic
sql and rather than just save it as a
dot sql file on my desktop and then
keep it in a special folder called
i don't know indispensable because it's
all things that make me indispensable at
my company
i'm actually going to modularize it
push it to github make it shareable make
it collaborative
uh make sure that other people in the
world can access it
so there's a couple steps to do here
and let's talk about them first off
what's the benefit for transforming my
data at all
well maybe you noticed some weirdness
around
the user id column in orders actually
mapping to the id and the customers
table
who knows exactly why that is maybe
it was initially a table of users
maybe we had a notion of users of my
jaffle ordering app before we had a
notion of
of customers of people actually paying
for and buying my sandwiches
there are some useful fields that i need
to build up and
at some point i don't want people to
have to write the same join logic
over and over and over when i know that
they're going to need some useful
recapitulation of orders and customers
every single time so i can connect the
bi tool directly to
that transform data
here's how to do this manually and
claire gave a good example here
it involves writing ddl create table
dev clear or my case create table
dbt jericho dot
fact customers as
all right should work this is going to
run against snowflake
i'm pretty sure that that's the syntax
and i'm pretty sure that it's right
all right that works well enough um
but let's say i actually want it to be i
don't know a view now i know my data is
always updating i want it to be always
up to date
all right it's an error well it already
exists as a table i would need to know
that i need to drop table
first and actually does the schema
already exist in this case i lucked out
and it did but if it didn't i would need
to create schema
dbt jericho well but i want to run this
and i also
don't want it to error if the schema
does already exist so secret schema if
it exists
anyway i'm belaboring a point but
this is boilerplate code at least we see
it as such
there's a talk right after this by some
folks from um
stitch fix who um i admire greatly and
have read their work and
one of the more famous bits they put out
in the world was engineers shouldn't
write etl
we also believe engineers shouldn't
write ddl
analytics engineers that is as much of
this boilerplate code as we can avoid
writing we should
and so instead of writing that
and handling all these cases we're going
to use
dbt so what do we need to use dbt data
warehouse
good you all anyone in the world can
spin up a free bigquery account
you can also spin up a snowflake trial
could also spin up a postgres database
locally
that's all you need just needs to be
able to run sql with data already loaded
into it
now postgres snowflake bigquery
red shifts these are not the four
databases in the world that can run sql
they are just the four
that are defined as core adapters within
dbt we're going to talk
much later today about what it looks
like to
use databases which are not in those
core4 it's totally possible all you need
is a data arrange that can run sql and
access data
using sql you need a dbt project
i instantiated mine right here just
totally from scratch
this is the dbt init function on the
command line
or the big green button in cloud
the project needs to have models in it
so we're going to make one in a second
and it's going to have a lot of yaml in
it for configuration
so models are just our select statements
no create table as no insert no delete
none of the ddl or dml those are
actually handled
in an abstraction layer that dvt gives
us so rather than needing to worry about
writing all of that wrapping
i'm actually just going to make a file
called customers
and hit dbt rug
create a replace view
it's there for me
let's try to make this even a little
trickier for ourselves
i don't want it as a view i want it as a
table
drop view if exists create replace
transient table
so as part of that abstraction layer dbt
even knows
hey i'm running on snowflake on
snowflake
i don't want jeremy to have to worry
about
paying for storage of all these objects
i'm creating and dropping over the
course of time
so by default enable transients
and those are just the kind of things
that we know about because
we've got a lot of people in the
community who have storage costs
realize that turning on transients by
default makes a lot of sense
make it even harder for myself
ah
okay i have no schema
i've got it now and it just works
so dbt needs to be able to connect to
the warehouse i took a little bit of a
digression there but that's okay fair
enough on the cli this looks like making
a file
um called profiles.yaml in a hidden
directory just so that you're not
checking any credentials into git
and cloud it looks like adding that same
kind of credentialing information
in the ui and then the command
as you've been seeing i've been running
dbt run i can also make this a little
more particular
just run my customers model here that's
going to have no effect i've got one
model
but all the same i'll talk a little bit
later about all of our
new and great ideas for how to make that
even more powerful
fair enough
so dbt connects parses my project
wraps all my models in the ddl that's
needed based on the state of the
database
executes the code to build all those
models into my target
schema in this case it's dbt jericho
me but i could set this up to
in production run with a totally
separate schema and that's the way that
dbt is environmental where
and we're able to separate between
development
my development your development someone
else's development
staging ci production
always having control over where dbt's
assets are going to end up
i've already been showing you a little
bit about this but how to see what's
going on
we've been looking at some of the debug
logs some of the details here
in the run status
broken down by model so this is the
sequel that dbt is actually running
against the database
this is ginger it's a pythonic
templating language
which we use to configure
and extend the sql that we run right now
we write
um i can also pop into my logs file here
or this get ignored target directory
to see just what i've got for my
customers model
and then the actual sql that's that's
run so there's lots of
lots of ways to figure out what's going
on none of this is meant to be
obfuscated it's all meant to be
transparent but also in a way where i
don't need to worry about it unless i
absolutely have to
we talked about this a little bit i
added the config materialized
there are four materialization types the
tbt knows about
by default view table ephemeral
incremental there are many many more
which you can
write yourself which people out in the
world have written themselves
these are again parts of the uh
constructs that dvt ships with but then
are extensible
um because it's meant to be a framework
not a
tight like so tight a view of the world
that there's no wiggle room
so as i said materializations build
strategies
analytics engineers shouldn't write ddl
except when they write it
functionally write it once use it
over and over again and no need to write
it if it's just create tableas
and then configurations are model
settings ways of
adjusting and adapting that behavior so
like materialize or like the ability to
tag things
enable them turn them on or off i could
also
for instance
turn off the transients
of my tables
if i got the sequel right probably not
i mean not the sequel i'm sorry the
configuration right
obviously i should be checking the docs
here but let's just see if i'll get it
on a hail mary
nice no more transients
so again connect to the data warehouse
parse the project
wrap those models in the appropriate ddl
dml
execute that sql to build models into
the target schema
now what about
having more than one model
i know that in other orchestration tools
there is a notion of a dag of a directed
acyclic
graph acyclic depends on how you want to
go with that
greek alpha primitive not cyclical
cannot start back over on itself
what if instead of this being all here
i actually want to make some new models
make it a little more modular
so now instead of rewriting that sequel
over again
i want to do something to the effect of
like select from my
version of the stage customers model
but then in production select from
whoops
that's a funny way to uh the production
version
of the stage customers model
well tbt's got a construct for that it's
the ref function
it's arguably the most important thing
we've got
and this will dynamically compile out to
whatever
the right version of the model is for
the given environment
for the configurations that i've given
select from
ref stage customers let's do the same
here stage
orders
okay i'm getting a configuration or
sorry a compilation error down below
depends on stage orders but it's not
found
rightly so i haven't made it yet
you'll see i'm still statically typing
the raw source of data here we'll get
there
everything looks good
so i've implicitly said
that customers depends on stage
customers and depends on
stage orders sdg here just meaning
it lies quite low to the to the source
data to the raw data i'm just
lightly touching it up i'm lightly
renaming ideas customer id
user id is customer id ideas order id
probably you know this is this is my
chance to um
make the data usable to me make it named
well
for the rest of my analytics ecosystem
so magically dbt just new
stage customers and stage orders need to
run before
customers because customers is going to
depend on those two
now we call those dependencies
the dag as well and unlike some other
orchestration tools where the dag needs
to be
explicitly architected this
depends on this then run this other
thing
simply by using those ref statements
we know how to compile them out in an
environment a way
aware way and dbt knows how to
um create the dag and then
infer from it the order to run models in
so that um we can get through it as
quickly and reliably
as possible
this totally removes the incentive to
have
hundreds of lines of sql at a time
defined in a given
file so this is a kind of silly example
but
when i'm doing laundry as i uh
do often enough because the laundry
machine is actually in my bedroom
in this house uh it's pretty funny i
need to
not insert quarters thankfully i i live
a blessed life but at least
insert laundry into the machine before i
wash it
i need to wash before i move the clothes
to the dryer move the clothes to the
dryer then fold
there's no way to move to the dryer
we'll then insert the laundry back into
the washing machine
again one needs to happen before the
other
um obviously this does recur
on a let's say weekly basis
for being generous but there is no
cycling back it is directed and is
unidirectional
this is a slightly more complex tag
handling
customer acquisition by marketing
channel and this is a real one with
real dbt models and then this is
a typical dag for i believe our internal
analytics project
here at fishtown
okay there's a couple more pieces that
are important to get through
um we'd be remiss to make this a
dbt workshop if we don't talk about
testing
rabbi hillel would say we have not
completed the mitzvah of
um talking about all that is possible in
dbt
uh we've already talked about matzah
this is the mar
what are tests tests are assertions that
we make
that we can define either as arbitrary
one-off sql
or more frequently as yaml
configurations
that then compile to functional sql
which runs against
our models when the assertion is true
the test passes
and it's just a select statement same as
models
so same as before
connect to the data warehouse parse the
project iterate through all those
resource files
execute sql for every single test
could make
write some tests
i believe that
the customer id column
should be unique whoops
and not null all of the time
i also feel the same way oops
about the order ie column in the stage
orders model
and uh
let's i also feel
that let's indeed rename it
the order status column order steps
should be one of a set of values that i
feel
good about i feel like i understand them
know how to deal with them
okay so that's my stage orders model
this is what i actually meant
to have typed
return completed return pending shipped
and placed
good enough i just want to say
those are the only values
that i'm going to accept
um i could write it like this i could
also make it a yaml list
i think that'll work
and then it's just a dbt test command
i've made a bunch of assertions i've
said a bunch of things that i believe to
be true
are they indeed true
looks good so far this is how we avoid
the situation i mentioned mentioned
earlier around
uh thinking a relationship thinking a
join
is one to one and it turns out it's one
to many well
the primary key that we think is unique
in this table
would turn out to not be so unique after
all
you can see what it looks like
when a test fails
okay i promise you what's running behind
the scenes
is just a sql statement value not in
my set of accepted values
what happens oh this icon is new i like
that
summary we had one failing record we had
one
value that is not in the set of values i
thought i was willing to accept
back to the drawing board or back to
figuring out what what happened
what went wrong with our data
so that kind of quality assurance the
ability to make assertions and then test
them
critical to any transformation pipeline
that i'm going to feel good about
because then i can also build these
models and run these tests
as part of a continuous integration
suite
anytime i'm proposing changes to my code
base anytime i'm opening a pull request
against the git repository that stores
the main branch of my transformation
logic which is deployed and automated on
a schedule
anytime i do that run all my models run
my tests
take a little bit later about smarter
ways to go about that um
but do both all green check marks i feel
good about merging my code
anything red and we're back to the
drawing board
so there's a bunch of helpful commands
especially if you are
working on the cli uh want to be able to
check the version of dbt that you're
using
we're coming out with new versions every
two months or so
just make sure that your connection to
the warehouse works the way you think it
does
compile your project this is done
implicitly by
anytime i run or test or do any other
commands there's a couple things that
aren't covered
in this uh presentation because we cover
them later on in the two-day course but
i'll talk about them
for just a little bit right now and then
open up the floor for thoughts questions
you all taking a spin at this maybe me
taking uh
a couple minutes to go get more coffee
so the couple things i want to talk
about
are ways to establish dependencies for
source data as well if you
saw me type this
maybe you're hoping you're thinking
there must be some way to type
uh ref source
travel shop customers maybe
and you'd be really close it's going to
look like this
source jaffle shop
customers
i'm getting an error down below that
says it depends on a source that i
haven't yet defined
hold your sources
jaffle shot oops
tables
customers
orders
let's do the same here
and i've actually got another node in my
dependency graph in my dag
which is now sources all the way up to
my final customers model
there's one other um pretty neat pretty
exciting
thing i can do and i'm going to
make sure i get the syntax right here
and that's actually test how fresh how
recent
my source data is
i haven't been loaded
if only
ymo is of course a very
indentation aware language configuration
mechanism whatever you want to call it
okay i've defined
a loaded ad field for my orders table in
particular
and a set of freshness expectations
about that field i think that the max
value of etl loaded at
the last time that records were added to
this table
should be ought to be no more than 12
hours
from this very moment 12 hours ago and
it better not be
more than 24 hours ago
and there's a command for that
um ah
on snowflake i set it up in the way that
any good snowflake account is set up
with my raw data in a different database
from my analytics data for my transform
data
okay i'm getting a warning it's a little
bit out of date
between 12 and 24 hours ago of course if
i
realize that's perfectly reasonable i
only won't run it once a day
i checked in with the data engineers i
checked in with stitch support 510
support for whomever
is responsible for getting this data to
me
i revise my expectations upward looks
good
or no it turns out we do
intraday reporting on our orders
so it ought never be more than an hour
old and had better never be more than
two
or else we are gonna have a skewed view
of the day
well that expectation is not borne out
by the data again this is just a select
statement this is just select max this
value
from your table it is something you can
and could write yourself
or something that you can configure like
this
um one other oops uh piece i want to
share is
you know these
this is all well and good um in terms of
writing code and writing code with with
clarity and hopefully a lot of
inline comments um but
this is something i hope to collaborate
on and share with other people and hand
off
to others someday a key part of that as
i mentioned earlier
is documentation documentation
documentation
so
i'm going to um put that pizza
i just made for everybody in the oven
for a second
take out the one already baked
let's take a look at a deployment run
of the demo project we've got here
and view the auto-generated
documentation site
powered by it
so this has a lot going on but this is
all code
just like the code we were writing all
code that we could write together we can
add descriptions
to models and actually push information
into the documentation site the
documentation site also
pulls a lot of information out of the
database
it pulls information metadata from the
project about tags
owner columns data types of those
columns from the database
as well as the source and compiled code
and then the ps3
the lineage graph the dag that i was
talking about earlier
auto generated inferred based on
those ref calls and those source calls
that i was typing just a few minutes ago
so these are as i see them
the core features of dbt
[Music]